to put a move on
[Music]
now a little dance lebron spinning
lebron shooting lebron scoring
right into gobert too i mean
right into gobert
hanging in the air absorbs the contact
and gets the score forces the jazz to
want to take a timeout there's three
minutes and 17 left as lebron puts it up
puts it in and it's a
94-91 game
he's against utah
and this is the second meeting of three
you know what frank vogel told us
russell westbrook played well against
golden state
played well tonight here
6-13
16 points limited his turnovers had an
assist
and closed the game out at the
free-throw line he had everybody take
extra free throws after that golden
state game and tonight it paid dividends
[Music]
that's a heck of a win
[Applause]
a magisterial performance
by lebron james
embraced by a super bowl champion
that's how they do it in la these days
mitchell an impressive line he had 37 to
go along with five assists
but not quite enough tonight
as lebron james and his 33 points eight
rebounds six assists
he scores 25 or more in his 23rd
consecutive game boy what a night
in the city of drama yeah you had to
muscle up and hustle up tonight
as lebron james leads the way as the
lakers win it 106 to 101 coming up next
sportscenter was scott van pelt for
doris burke
i'm mark jones saying so long from los
angeles
[Music]